our next speaker is edward cook charles
f montgomery professor of the history of
art and director of the center for of
study in american decorative arts and
material culture as well as professor of
american studies
professor cook focuses upon american
material culture and decorative arts his
books include making furniture in
pre-industrial america the social
economy of newtown and woodbury
connecticut
and inventing boston design production
and consumption in the atlantic world
1680-1720
both of which focus upon the context of
craftsman-client relations in colonial
north america
he's also written extensively on modern
craft is historicizing and explicating
more recent forms of production and has
been co-curator and publication author
of six different exhibitions
he is currently writing global objects
towards a connecticut
connected sorry art history
cook's work in expanding the field of
decorative arts has led to several
awards including the iris foundation
award for outstanding contribution to
the decorative arts the furniture
society's award of distinction election
as an honorary fellow of the american
craft council and college art
association's distinguished teacher of
art history award please welcome
professor cook
[Applause]
thanks so much matthew it's uh it's
really nice to be participating in this
idea of interdisciplinary humanities to
reassert the fact that humanities is not
a
dead um kind of topic in an age of big
data and
different kinds of stem but actually
thinking can we
look at humanities in a expanded field
in some ways and
in some
when i have started to get into
the dealing with objects within an art
history department which used to be
considered
the minor arts in the old slide library
how do you make them part of
the real center of a discipline like art
history um
and one of the moves that i felt like
was really essential is traditional art
history has been very ocular central um
that is it's all about the eye the eye
and the mind and its visual
analysis and
sometimes you might describe it as being
object centered
some would even say object or maybe art
obsessed work of art obsessed
and i wanted to flip that a little bit
and talk about um object-driven kinds of
inquiry in other words think about
objects from the inside out rather than
the outside in
and sometimes not even thinking about
the end of just sort of staying on the
surface
and so part of what i've been
about particularly within the last 10
years is
developing a sense of what i call
material literacy or
maybe material intelligence
that is knowledge of materials and
techniques and how those can lead to
new and innovative questions and i think
of this not as a substitute for
digital humanities but actually it's
complementary in terms of how we might
open up
the idea of humanities into a broader
sensibility
so one of the things that's really key
is
again sort of
thinking about the stability of
materials and um and techniques versus
the
permeability there's so many
possibilities of materials techniques
and it what really leads to this idea
that i've developed in this new book
about interconnected art history it's
not a linear path from a to b but
actually it's got multiple layers
directions that are layered up on top of
one another to create this kind of rich
mix
so how do you go about
teaching
from the inside out
in some respects and part of
this
and sue walker knows this uh well in
terms of my interest in
asking questions of materials
that is
i was always struck by people when i was
doing my graduate work who would just
simply
stay true to ideas of style terms um and
to me
i always had questions you know why did
somebody over theorize the carving of a
panel in the denim medfield chests and
talked about the use of these compasses
to lay out all these different lines and
i decided to do a carving exercise
having never done something like this
and realized a compass is used in four
different areas but that's it the rest
of it is guided by the the curve of the
carving gouge if you had the right four
tools
i could carve that in 20 minutes
light bulb goes off they over theorize
it without understanding sort of from
the inside out and so i did a number of
uh projects while i was writing my
dissertation um that i was asking
questions that had come up in uh
what i was studying what i was writing
about it's a great way to actually write
a dissertation
making things at the same time
it then continued on
as i tried to acquire
not that i was going to become a
full-time maker i had no illusions of
this whatsoever but could i expose
myself to trying different things
so doing a a turning residency down in
pennsylvania for a week working with
these international
turning stars from france from australia
from the united states
learning some basics being able to make
a series of objects with each of them so
to spending a day with each of these
international residents
and sort of working within their vein
if you will and realizing
contrary to most what most people
thought a lathe is not a
industrial tool that predetermines the
result it's merely a tool
um and you can use it in multiple ways
i follow that trying glassblowing trying
block printing anywhere everywhere i go
and visit makers
throughout the world
i'll try my hand at something
i'll try hammering copper and puna um
and what you end up in here is like
learning to work on the ground and
learning to use your feet
using other parts of your body as a way
of biomechanic feedback and how that
affects
the work posture
and counters kind of a a western
perspective on
serious work you stand at a bench
and you sort of are upright the whole
time
and you sort of over jig some of your
tools here you know working on the
ground there are many different
advantages for certain types of work so
it's this kind of exploration that was
so key
that i then wanted to take into the
classroom
and one of the things that's really
such a strength of teaching
any kind of art history yale obviously
is collections and it's not just the
museums themselves
and what's on view but it's also what's
in storage it's the
conservation department of the
scientific research department of ipch
these are all
ways of thinking about objects from the
inside out and so when i teach classes
what i'm most often trying to do is say
yes
visual analysis is important but so is
touch so it's feeling the heft of
something feeling surface being able to
turn something upside down look inside
of it
and so a lot of my courses with the help
of colleagues at the art gallery have i
don't know any other
university museum that dedic museums
that dedicate so much space to study
rooms
in which you can bring objects off of
you
and you can handle things you can pass
them around um
many different uh i've been to uh
different gatherings and the melon
foundation has funded in terms of trying
to get museum people and academics
together and
there's some people who feel so excited
that they pass objects around in trays
no touching but just passing around and
trade and think that's education
what it is it's fear of objects in some
respects and
what's wonderful is the way in which
colleagues here
work with you to establish the right
parameters to make this a safe endeavor
to make sure that students are trained
teaching fellows are trained and how to
handle objects how to model good
behavior with objects so that the
students
actually become the most respectful
kinds of users of the collection they
understand responsibility if you
tell them about it you give it to them
you model it for them
so this is just sort of um
what i do is i teach teaching fellows
how to teach with objects rather than in
in front of them which i think is
another really important kind of
maneuver
and then they go ahead um and teach
their students
so what you're doing is you're having
effect on two different generations of
scholars but the graduate students
learning how to teach with objects as
well as the undergraduate exposure to
kinds of questions they could ask of
objects in terms of this kind of global
perspective
and so here's it
you can tell it's mask time from 2021 um
and we are back in the classroom
teaching um this was the hardest thing
to of course to teach
object driven inquiry remotely
we tried to get around it but there's
nothing like the satisfaction and the
students you could tell not only were
they happy to be back in the classroom
together but they also
liked being around objects uh yet again
there are wonderful resources not simply
in central campus but west campus
becomes this a wonderful area where
you've got collection study centers
the whole furniture study which used to
be on york street is out there and
becomes this incredible lab that's
basically open stack storage if you want
to use a library term that you can
browse
that i actually run a a first year
seminar to get somebody early on in
their career and get people who are
engineers who are
art majors who might be history majors
um
quite a swath of people who might take
this course
and we meet that's the classroom the
furniture study
we go out in the shuttle every week one
o'clock shuttle we're out there for two
hours i can run class on the shuttle as
roxanna was nice to get a dedicated
shuttle so i could actually have q a and
some other kind of housekeeping on the
way out
and then also being able to teach
graduate seminars um that would often
times involve handling looking talking
about objects um
with them right with us not just looking
at images
the wordle study center where a lot of
the collections of non-furniture
materials um
from american decorative arts um
ceramics glass textiles etc
it's an amazing again open storage but
unlike the loose center at the met which
is just encased in captivity in plexi
this is all
you can call things and bring them out
for a particular class so with denise
leite who's the curator of asian art
we ran a joint class on on lacquer in a
global context not just east asian
lacquer but also japaning from europe
and america
to talk about
non-bond
export ware from japan
but handling things looking at things
asking questions of the objects as we
looked inside of them was a critical
part of it
i've also tried to
sort of follow the principles of john
dewey learning by doing
um and
what i tried to do is sort of put making
exercises into various different courses
initially in the old furniture study
they had sort of a shop and i would
bring in um a friend of mine peter
fallinsby who used to be the joiner at
plymouth plantation an open air museum
up in massachusetts and we
worked out sort of different exercises
we could do within two hours to give
students a chance to split out green
wood to plane it to learn how to do some
preliminary carving not to make
something in its entirety but just get a
few principles
this is something that i've done carried
forward as another part of west campus
scott strobel when he was head of west
campus gave me a space out there
to use as a low-tech maker space that i
could store some tools some materials
out there
and i started to incorporating this so
that's where i've done uh woodworking
now on the left for uh first year
seminar in 2019
i had another one
class on vessels in which we
won
class we ended up hammering copper disks
into bowls to learn something about um
hammering uh the malleability of metal
this is um
again sort of a green woodworking i did
for this material literacy and then
embodied artisanal knowledge using just
basic tools like clubs froze
hatchets
and knives
and
sending people to work the advantage of
fall in new england
you can work outside so
one year we were carving spoons uh on
west campus around the fire pit um it
wasn't available this year
so we went to one of the courtyards of
west campus and the collections study
center
with a shaving horse
again hatchets froze splitting out wood
green moist wood and then
working on different spatulas and
the like
all this is
working closely with different kinds of
artisans um so peter fallinsby um andre
scar says we're helpful with the wood
joan parcher a metal smith up in
providence
i've worked with her to developing a
very basic kit of tools that i could
give students to work with
making copper discs learning how to
shape something
with a ball-peen hammer
on a
on a steel block
i worked with andrew hamilton
developing another session on spinning
and fiber
and watching students get frustrated
trying to use a drop spindle um
you know these very basic uh sorts of
endeavors but you learn so much about
the materials and the feedback on them
that you can just see um the ways in
which when you have them uh students in
class the way they get absorbed time
flies
for them
i've also sent out kits ceramic kits
metal kits
and weaving kits to students for the
undergraduate class that they do
in their own dorms this was a covid
related sort of endeavor and again
students just raved about do learning
off-screen
and being able to sort of
learn so much and then apply what
they've learned in the grappling with
the material to their own work
again with andrew we did some weaving
this is some of the cardboard loom
weaving we did for the undergraduate
just
providing them with uh cotton warp
thread warp cardboard that sets up at
the loom and then a series of acrylics
that are sort of wool-like
so this is two different students work
just completed this year
i've worked with mark potter to work on
sort of
different sorts of recipes for clay
that you know you can add different
elements to it you can create different
sorts of appearances
we did this exercise in which we gave
students an hour in which they worked
with
prescribed
proportion recipes to make something and
then we gave them unlimited materials
and had them
measure out and these were the measuring
devices they had just a piece of wood
with holes drilled in it so they had to
work out proportions in their minds
of what these materials were going to do
this is the kit of tools we used to then
work with either regular clay
mixed or we could start add in different
kinds of ingredients that made their own
recipe
once they made them
we made them making test strips to see
you know hear these different uh
formulas
when they fired some of them didn't do
so well they shrunk they
bent around some of them were not very
stable and some of them were disasters
i feel like some of the students didn't
know when you when you're baking for
instance you do dry ingredients first
and then add liquid there were some
people who did liquid first
and just peeled all the we were working
on sheetrock and it just like made a
mess on the boards that they were
working on you learn a lot along the way
and then these are just some of the
objects i had everybody do a test strip
and an object
with a
given formula that they had to mix and
then also with their own invention
what i've done recently for the
undergraduates is working with penelope
von grinsvin who's
taken on responsibility of the five
undergraduate pottery studios is to
develop a kit that you could coil and
this um so it has a folding board with
canvas a cutting wire
two and a half pounds three pounds of
clay a bucket with a sponge you know um
instead of a needle tool a rib
everything you need to make
objects like this these are not thrown
on a wheel these are all coiled or slab
construction these are undergraduates
this past fall
um this semester who are making these
sorts of things with this kind of
exercise just giving clay abandoning
wheel to sort of like a lazy susan just
to get some sort of sense of what's
possible
so
you know in teaching material literacy
yale's got this incredible opportunity
in terms of access to collections things
that will inspire you
ways to then try out making yourself
exposed to different sorts of materials
and then also taking that knowledge back
to the classroom looking handling at
objects not simply looking at them under
a vitrine and it's just a couple things
that are important to this idea of the
pedagogy of teaching
object-driven inquiry
is in addition to having objects study
classrooms in abundance and it's
wonderful to see the peabody with their
renovations doing the same thing
but to
also start to realize well if you can
have a messy space can you design
um can you sort of work with
sympathetic knowledgeable makers nobody
one person can do it all so oftentimes
it's a collaboration um like to and
throwing with joan parcher what would be
a good exercise what i tried the first
time didn't work
and that's when i got her into the
conversation
these are things that you know i was
never trained in it but it's wonderful
to sort of develop these ideas together
and then i think the other thing that's
important is thinking about time
in terms of what's what can you
accomplish within two hours
what's a project and so many yale
students are
perfectionists who have an idea of what
they want to make and you have to get
them to shift that aside and think just
go with a process don't worry about
what you want to exert your will on
something what can you learn
along the way so it's been a fabulous
kind of
path to to go down to thinking about the
material humanities in some respects
into thinking about what yale really
allows us to do
and i hope that you get a chance to sort
of visit with some of the other
information tables
from
the
just thinking of
the wordle center in the art gallery
study centers on west campus of the ipch
institute for preservation of cultural
heritage and the research scientists
there conservation
staff for the various museums it's this
kind of package that you've got so many
people you can turn to
to ask questions
and to work together to sort of move
some of this project forward
so i'm happy to answer questions this i
just want to sort of
tempt you in terms of what's possible
[Applause]
i'm happy to start off so
when we were talking about the digital
humanities the question of sort of the
skills the coding skills and whatnot
that
are needed are not sort of part of the
curriculum that we understand are there
ways in which you can see this sort of
work being incorporated into curriculum
or how you've
yeah i mean what i've managed to do the
question is um how to
integrate this into a curriculum and
that's why i wanted to actually show
what i've been doing in some of the
classes
so with the undergraduates i haven't
necessarily
other than the furniture class i haven't
taught them in class time itself
but i developed these kits last year
when people were remote um that actually
had them pick up or mailed to them if
they were truly off campus
and they would make things photograph
them and then ship the kit well the
weaving kit was inexpensive so that was
just a throwaway but the um the ceramic
kit and the metal kit ended up
investing 25 to 35 dollars for each of
those kits
so
that's a way in which
i felt like that became an assignment
you know making and reflecting and
really giving them parameters in which
they could succeed
and they had to write reflections as i
said so they're they're it's not just
simply
winging it and then you know that's the
end of it but by reflecting
and giving them prompting certain
questions was a way to
dig deeper um into what this meant in
terms of the course for the graduate
students um
i do it within class because you've got
a longer period of time um and and i
will try to develop say three or four
making exercises over the semester um so
this course i'm teaching now on embodied
knowledge
we did woodworking first and that the
emphasis there was on the materials what
does the material what's the agency of
the material because it's green wood and
it's it's going to go the way it wants
to go um so you have to work with it and
then when we did metal um it was about
um thinking about the body because i had
them working at a bench on the ground
sitting all sorts just kept moving their
body positions around to get them
finding what's the right way and again
they had to write reflections and then
we just did pottery on
on wednesday and
there i was trying to get them to focus
on the hand and again having them on the
ground at a wheel coiling
all sorts of different movements so
there's a way to do it to incorporate it
and then there's also like the
undergraduates have this opportunity
in the residential colleges that there
are a number of different studios like
five pottery studios there's a weaving
studio in morrison styles
but it's harder for the graduate
students to gain access to that
but it's not you know i'm not running an
art school course either um so you know
it's that fine line um it's gotta tie
into
the theme the reading the intellectual
content uh of the course
but i was also wondering if you teach
this
to faculty
i
have there was
there have been a couple times that
i had the opportunity to have
a teach-in
on west campus
that was designed for graduate students
faculty and museum people
and i had different themes and brought
different people into run
different sorts of projects so
one was on this idea of
[Music]
spoons i mean we sort of have a session
which we had
makers artists talk about their practice
so that one day a second day would be
making things on west campus and the
third day
would be about
exhibition practice
so there was one year we did one uh that
had sort of uh the idea of
reproducibility that we had spoons we
cast spoons we carved spoons we made
clay spoons we hammered copper spoons
and just kept rotating people around
always working with the same spoon and
yet also had
andres garces who was working
in conservation at that point um he had
scanned one of these spoons and then
we did 3d printing
as well as cnc
subtractive technology and wood and
started working off of
what's the difference between a cast
pewter spoon and a
cnc
cut out spoon or a
3d printed spoon um and it was great
conversations just to sort of explode
that there was another year we talked
about um
the idea of uh of repair um and um
in in different kinds of uh
it's a recalibration that we had
christina kim who's a textile artist
come in and talk about in a sewing
circle um we had sam thomas uh
hotness sony beater who came in and
led a beating exercise to talk about
reconciliation that he's been doing with
the
canadian boarding schools
indigenous people
and was just incredible to think about
reconciliation repair um and how
making and materials really lend
themselves to this easygoing
conversation
so that's that's been one thing um
it's hard to do it every year um instead
of just coming up with these ideas
trying to mobilize people i think in
terms of stories um anecdotes of um
it's
i mean what what i've really been struck
by with a graduate seminar than when
we're working with different materials
watching people all of a sudden just
relax
and start to
realize
i don't have to be a perfectionist i'm
just i'm going with the flow the idea of
flow and you know
one of the topics that's come up this
year is what does focus mean what is
concentration what is absorption um and
how can you be focused in an area
where you're all hammering and all
sudden like that
that white noise starts to become a way
that you create your own little bubble
versus
being outdoors on a beautiful fall day
and you're just using a simple little
sloyd knife doing your final cuts on a
spatula and you're just you know
you're completely removed from the world
um so it's it's it's interesting to just
sort of watching people's bodies relax
watching
when they're social with one another
when they're sort of looking uh at their
own work and you start to see that how
it affects the way in which they're
talking about objects uh in subsequent
classes i don't know if that answers
some of your question
thanks cindy thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you